eu não sei que em petrópolis e aos 17
anos eu fui para são paulo em busca de
um sonho eu queria estudar nas melhores
faculdades do país e de seis anos depois
de conseguir por um algumas delas
minha mãe meu irmão está aqui na sala
estiver a chata tarefa de assistir em 12
horas e meia de colação de grau com 24
anos é formado em direito na usp
economia administração do insper que são
escolas de excelência nas suas áreas
isso já fazia com as pessoas esperassem
que fosse logo um cara bem sucedido
somado a isso a longa trajetória
acadêmica eu tive a oportunidade de
participar de grandes grupos e conhecer
pessoas incríveis grandes empreendedores
como jorge paulo beto e marcel também
deve o abílio da ponte açúcar e agora
carrefour e todo mundo esperar o grande
momento que eu viria aqui no ted e
contaria como fundema mais natascha
milionária e agora mora no vale do
silício ou que eu sou mais jovem diretor
de uma grande empresa
na verdade não foi o que aconteceu hoje
eu sou por uma carta do carnaval carioca
nos últimos seis anos
tenho trabalhado entretenimento carioca
isso é verdade mas é uma vez com uma só
vez por ano
na verdade o trabalho de uma ong e isso
muitas vezes choca mais ações do que eu
tô com essa história hoje uma missão ela
entrega óculos
há pessoas que não podem pagar e muita
gente fala ah você pode fazer isso
talvez seja o ric o culpado e quer fazer
algo diferente ou que se ela abrir mão
da minha do meu sonho é poder ajudar os
outros e também seja uma ótima grandes e
na verdade não e é um pouco de
descontrole hoje porque é concluída em
2013 na faculdade ainda eu ganhei um
prêmio e foi prata e empreendedorismo
social entre universitário e 36 países e
lá o time da alemanha na verdade munique
e chamou bastante atenção mais até do
que as holandesas do planeta
lá o cão com
era 180 milhões de pessoas no mundo foi
um par de óculos não podiam pagar e
aquilo me assusto meus olhos ele pegar
ele escolhe uma tecnologia que pode um
óculos de grau de custos levaram para a
áfrica ensinar as pessoas a usar as
pessoas conseguiram emprego com a
tecnologia será que isso é um problema
só da áfrica da ásia
ou será que no brasil falta óculos na
bolha que vivia nas melhores faculdades
de todo mundo que precisava usava óculos
e eu fui estudar esse problema aqui eu
descobrir que o maior motivo da evasão
escolar segundo o programa alfabetização
solidária do mec é deficiente visual
você pode terminar a escola pública do
mundo um é função do mundo têm crianças
entra naquela última fileira lá ela não
enxerga é a burrinha ela desinteressada
ou ela bagunceira e além disso o mesmo
tempo escolar entre os 100 países como o
idh
então um quarto das crianças hoje
abandonam a escola muitas dificuldades
o motivo então a gente viu que o
problema é muito grande com essa máquina
a gente fazer um óculos que era 20% mais
20% do preço humor tradicional
além disso descobriu outro dado ainda
mais relevante talvez não tão mais
relevante mas que 27 milhões e meio de
brasileiros em idade economicamente
ativa precisam de óculos e não sabem
então pode a gente nessa sala que
precisa óculos não sabe e que o mosto de
fora fala que eu apenas social de uma
pessoa que usa óculos é de r 768 dólares
por ano se não usa porque ela tem mais
um acidente de trabalho e é menos
produtiva se multiplica o número pelo
outro chega ao absurdo valor que o custo
social de pessoas que não enxergam no
brasil é de 24 bilhões de dólares
então isso a gente agir realmente trazem
a tecnologia pra cá vamos mudar evasão
escolar e vamos realmente trazer
atividade e seu e recurso nosso país em
dois anos eu comecei a faculdade ainda a
gente já entregou mais de 8 mil óculos
no país
quando temos ambição 8 mil óculos a
gente treina em dois anos mas ó cujo
estado de são paulo entregou em 3 na
visão do futuro é um programa do governo
e com muito menos recursos mais
eficiente ea gente pensou assim nossa
legal que pode fazer também ajudam
tempero brasileiro esse projeto as
pessoas que produziu esses óculos
pessoas em vulnerabilidade social
moradores de rua refugiados pessoas
comunidade
seguindo o mesmo tempo dá o ok mais
baratos do mercado e outro lado
realmente potencializar pessoas em
vulnerabilidade em dois anos também a
gente teve 11 produtores
quem tirou pra eles quase 150 mil reais
de renda eles tiveram oportunidade de
estudar com mais de três mil horas
ele foi muito interessante ressalta que
orgulha bastante e admitir um outro
problema que 85% dos municípios do
brasil então eu estava jogando sujo
então já estava nada a gente só leva ao
office negócio médico ele montou esse
ônibus tem dois consultórios dentro
depois evoluiu para um console portátil
uma mala e hoje quem mais precisa
mas muito mais do que números 8 mil 150
mil reais de renda
suas histórias que tive nesse caminho
2000 mostraram bastante e cada pessoa
trabalha com a gente tem sua história e
se emocionou
a primeira é da itália ali eu moro
repartimento e o é a quatro horas de
barco de manacapuru e ficou uma hora e
meia de barro de carro de manaus
a itália tinha o sonho de medicina mesmo
posto mais próximo fica a cinco horas de
distância no mínimo e ela sobre ghajar
uma das alunas mais destacadas da
comunidade e quando fez o exame com ela
ajudou bastante e do dia eu tinha 7
graus de miopia e a gente está ali a
itália como uma luva destacadas em seus
estudos em sessões
a mãe contou que ela pegava tudo que eu
falava não chegava eu estava só com a
voz e quando ao intervalo até o quadro
copiava o resto é detalhe era guerreira
agora quando as pessoas desistem de
estudar
o motivo tão simples vamos mudar um
pouco de idade
seu josé demorava uma hora de barco de
belém barcarena
eu já tinha 42 a miopia e quando ele
botou o office ele nunca tinha usado ele
começou a chorar compulsivamente
eu não preciso mais subir eu não preciso
mais subir vai subir em subir a onde meu
filho e resumo da história
seu josé lhe contava sair com 110 metros
de altura eu tinha que ficar lá chegava
lá em cima a fruta está ruim parecia
ganho de produtividade são josé tem pra
ele pra família dele hoje o produto tão
simples
e foram dois anos na faculdade eu tocava
o projeto e as pessoas começaram a me
perguntar legal parabéns mas quando vai
trabalhar de verdade né
e eu também acreditava nisso
sempre trabalho processo seletivo de
grandes empresas na vitrine efetivo para
os vários diferentes pensar em negócios
que podia fazer e esse ano uma notícia
pegou bem sua surpresa mas já nada minha
de 22 anos ela teve um câncer bem grave
com mais pressa bem clichê
aquilo me pegou bem na veia coisa é
pensar que a vida pode acabar tão rápido
o que eu quero fazer pra mim é você
pensar bastante
e no eu mais vejo assim quando
questionado se continuava a pressão das
pessoas de continuar e tem um trabalho
de verdade e no final de março eu
aceitei a proposta de uma grande empresa
eu estava pronto daquele momento de
assumir o último nos 2 semanas como
gestor desse projeto
o alemão que inventar uma máquina para o
brasil porque queria conhecer a operação
aqui e eu estava pronto pra falar pra
ele que eu treinei um sucessor e que
embora duas semanas super divertida de
voltar à zona de novo quem quer conhecer
mais o rio keve amazônia sempre né
e no último dia a gente sentou no
restaurante indiano e eu ia falar pra
ele que eu ia sair e eu não conseguia
falar pra ele isso e acho que eu falasse
ele perguntou com seu sonho em cinco
anos no projeto e hoje falar que eu ia
sair eu falei um milhão de óculos é ele
bem alemão falou olha a meta global era
um milhão eu sou para 2 entrega um pode
ser eu a pode né porque não seguiram a
sexta-feira começa a trabalhar na
segunda e voltei a me questionar o que
eu ia fazer eu tinha muito medo de
cancelar aqueles trabalhos que o super
bonito no papel
e pra jogar uma tarefa difícil diferente
ao mesmo tempo o banco eu fazer planos
liderança e eu lembrei de uma informação
que essa pesquisa 65 anos richard lyder
ele montou essa pesquisa e perguntou
para várias pessoas com 65 anos de idade
o que elas teriam feito diferente na
vida delas e na verdade elas falaram é
que não tinham arrependimento do que
elas fizeram
mas na verdade ela se arrependeu porque
elas não fizeram e principalmente no
terceiro ponto que ela criou muito
rápido muito mais cedo ter encontrado um
propósito na vida delas
então aqui consegui continuar aquele
medo do que as pessoas vão achar virou
na verdade o medo de fazer parte desse
número
eu tomei decisão sim vão embora
fazer um milhão de órfãos no brasil em
2021 e aí você vê a china é hoje
entregue o foco em dois anos então uma
média de 4 mil óculos por ano
eu tinha que se eu votasse o ano eles
planejamento preparação trazendo gente
eu tinha que entregar 250 mil por ano ou
seja eu tenho que explicar e sessenta e
duas vezes e meia o resultado no projeto
de uma rápida e eu gostei foi assim olha
eu vi uma conta de padeiro e eu percebi
que eu precisava de mais ou menos 150
milhões de reais em quatro anos para
entregar um milhão de óculos em que mais
precisava olhar suave e vamos buscar a
entidade que fazem isso no mundo e vão
entender o que elas fizeram para captar
e eu fui lá estados unidos onde o berço
do terceiro setor e eu vi um dado que
barrou um pouco que o desde os anos 70
só 104 entidade sem fins lucrativos
chegar na barreira 50 milhões de dólares
eo jazz unido está mil anos-luz avançado
em relação a seu retorno do que o brasil
lá eles investidos bilhões de dólares
por ano nessa área eu falei que do outro
lado tinha 46 mil empresas que foi um
sucesso e eu pensei olha se aquele lá já
é difícil imagina aqui e assim vamos
tentar melhorar essa estatística e vou
tentar unir um pouco e voltar ele falou
um pouco dos dois como a gente faz uma
visão de negócio o terceiro setor e vai
dar um diferente de impacto e foi aí que
eu comecei a me questionar se você
tentar lembrar daqueles com empresários
que houve tanto falar na faculdade onde
você olha o embate então vai ser uma
empresa sem fins lucrativos mas confio
superavitário e já pensar em um modelo
de negócio que já fazia isso acontecer
há aí um modelo de negócio para isso
acontecer
e às vezes você olha é de receber o
recurso lembra das histórias daqueles 8
mil óculos gente mas o que muita gente
poderia ter pago os 29 30 reais que o
óculos custa e passou a vender agora a
sua obra por 30 reais para quem transita
do sul
hoje o dito popular parceira tem pessoas
que gostam da sua obra tem mais de
receita mais dinheiro eu vendo pra elas
11 óculos 10 59 89 e subsidia um ou dois
quando ação ativo que era um ônibus que
estava parado durante a semana e vai ser
vender porque as nossas ações aconteceu
sempre de semana de dois finais de
semana eles vendem para as empresas
pedir atendimento
che guevara é preciso desenhar alguns
modelos de negócios em outras
estratégias têm hoje e com isso esperava
que esse modelo de negócio geram a gente
realmente investe para tentar chegar
àquelas pessoas que não têm condição
nenhuma de pagar isso algumas pessoas
começaram a ter um questionamento quanto
a isso acho que é contadora falou que
queria montar uma ong que vendia óculos
o primeiro falou nossa que lavar
dinheiro eu faço não é o segundo no
nosso canal dinheiro eu faço mas é mais
caro e olha eu terceiro aceitou a
entender um pouco o propósito deles
tinha que continuar evoluindo neco e eu
tentei lembrado pelas palestras
a gente viu que vai construir negócios
que têm essa crescimento
aqueles grandes perdedores sempre
falavam três palavras foco atrair mais
ainda
a gente ficou focada num sonho grande no
sonho e como eu trago gente boa pra
fazer isso a gente percebeu que o
propósito é muito importante a gente
também tinha muitas pessoas que tinham
medo de sair das suas carreiras
tradicionais que as pessoas acham legal
para tentar pôr um obscuro talvez tenha
que abrir mão de seus sonhos
eles é que não precisa abrir mão dos
seus sonhos e objetivos pessoais também
vai poder trabalhar e causa impacto
então hoje a gente montou um modelo e as
pessoas podem sim ser remuneradas de
acordo com o mercado de trabalho elas
fazem dando um exemplo de um produto na
hora da gente boa pra conversou com a
gente e ele foi buscar dinheiro para
fazer isso aí está sendo um exemplo é
que foi buscar tanto 15 mil reais de
doação muito tempo técnico e se 15 mil
reais para uma pessoa olha eu investi em
óculos cara legal pode ser ajudaria 515
óculos não contava temática rápida mas a
gente está validada
senti-me se uma pessoa boa que foi
destino nossos produtos que compõem o
pacote continuam na empresa ela venderia
no meio cerca de oito mutirões geraram
um superávit de 66.000 descontadas
despesas lógico tem muito mais coisa
envolvida mas ela entregaria 800 officer
da empresa e no final da última linha
que a linha que importa pra gente é de
2.285 óculos para entregar muito nosso
parceiro falou não invista foco nas
pessoas porque no máximo a nossa regra
aqui dentro a gente só deixa 10% para
administrativo de você que é isso mas as
pessoas precisam de óculos que em 2007 e
alguns parceiros continuarão falando que
não
por que não eu conheço e gosto olha como
ele contratou um escritório de advocacia
de eficácia não fica meio chateado
quando boto charge área e faz o seu
trabalho
então fico então quando se quer agora
fazer um impacto real e terceirizar o
impacto do que você deveria fazer da sua
empresa e quer fazer
tem muita gente boa pra fazer para
escalar eu ou ele vai dar oxigênio
bonitinho e entender isso algumas
pessoas vão acreditar nesse sonho mas
vou começar realmente focar trazer
recurso a vantagem é boa a banda skalla
e realmente ser fácil mas não faço mais
longe mas menos difícil entregar 1
milhão de ovos até 2021
outra coisa que eu queria fazer ele
queria tomar risco então hoje é meio
feio pra de onde vazou óleo fazer algo
pra tomar risco e deixou dinheiro para o
que talvez seja incerto
ele teve uma idéia no começo desse ano
ea gente queria fazer um estágio de
férias um programa de festas gente do
brasil inteiro a trabalhar com a gente
ea gente gastava menos 30.000 nisso ele
foi buscar vários parceiros e todos eles
falar senão eu dou 30 mil atletas dos
óculos não gente vai dar certo vai
trazer mais óculos e ninguém acreditou
na gente a gente pegou um fundo de caixa
reserva e estava muito na idéia da gente
boa poder fazer isso e as 30 mil
multiplicaram por quatro e um beijo
ele conseguiu refinanciar muito mais
ações que financia direto então eu tive
que várias pessoas tinham preconceito
ele não pode portar o terceiro setor
como negócio
isso continua a investir em marketing
também ead é uma plataforma que foi
proposto foi de graça de uma empresa a
poder investir para depois de conseguir
ganhar ea gente vê muita coisa faz nossa
você pega o jeito doação para investir
em post patrocinado no facebook não tem
que fazer óculos falei tenho mas vou
fazer óvulos relaxa e ponto que foi que
aconteceu é que me é o futebol foi sorte
que a plataforma de graça
mas além de provocar e já se pagando ela
o retorno que ela teve em doação e
crescimento de de caixa para poder virar
óculos foi quatro vezes
então em quatro meses eu estava dando
mais valor do que a plataforma em si e
hoje consegui pegar mais óculos que eu
só pegar o valor realmente doação direta
então o convite que eu tenho um pouco
para fazer a gente faz a gente tem
preconceito de pensar porque várias
coisas aconteceram no passado ante o
terceiro setor
a gente consegue fazer realmente o
escalava o quanto vai fazer as doações o
que realmente terceirizar porque o vi
fazer algo bom
pensa na verdade não qual são do
trabalho exatamente o dinheiro vai
andrade qual o sonho e as organizações
têm realmente transformar o brasil ea
gente começou a desenhar muito isso
quando várias pessoas têm preconceito
ainda é a grande força confiar e últimos
seis meses
neste modelo a realmente expandir fazer
algo diferente
a gente acabou de abril história em
florianópolis depois de levar um pisão
região sul do brasil é o que não está no
nosso planejamento mas teve gente boa e
compartilhou sonho com a gente agora
está em negociação e deve acontecer em
breve
o primeiro história na região nordeste e
manaus também na região norte
estamos a crescer porque começou a
pensar que a gente podia fazer algo de
negócio o setor e que esse valor
esperava que esse retorno seja
reinvestido é um pouco a pensar mais um
pouco porque eu queria trazer receita
identificou com a história e hoje ainda
uma pesquisa na página de galope que 87%
das pessoas não estão engajados no
trabalho porque não tem propósito neles
e eu queria eu tenho essa dúvida eu
queria muito fazer parte da estatística
do filho que a decisão também não sabia
dessa tática antes do meu convite e pra
terminar vou contar uma ótima história
que quando estava no projeto
voltei daquele campeonato é que a os
alemães apresentaram apresentando
renovation na verdade isso foi lá na
áfrica do sul
depois apresentou foi super legal a
gente ficou entre os seis projetos de
maior impacto hoje 16 melhores do mundo
e vai ser legal pra apresentar vão
viajar um pouco conhecer também já estão
aqui nem ganhou pra ir pra lá e pra
fazer essa ponte
essa ponte é o bangu shopping e podia
pagar 200 dinheiro só dele para ir lá lá
e olhar ou você podia pagar 700
engenheiros e pular
cara eu não quero pular esse negócio e
eu paguei foi a voz eo olhar de uma foca
bonitinho legal e quando cheguei lá
embaixo eu vi uma frase que eu já mostra
muito punk uma frase o medo é temporário
o arrependimento é permanente
naquele momento eu você pensa nossa eu
me joguei
eu acho que minha mãe fica brava de bens
até hoje a marca mas o que eu quero
convidar vocês é que vocês têm medo de
buscar o seu propósito
esses têm medo de fazer parte dessa
estatística
se joga e vai que dá muito obrigado
galera